let's analyze a one-dimensional
collision where we're in the laboratory
reference frame and we have v1 initial
and v2 initial is zero
it's a frictionless surface but there's
a collision here and now we're going to
make this collision totally inelastic
now what that means is that the two
particles stick together so if this is
our initial state and let's again choose
a direction I had then our final state
will just stick those two particles
together and they're going to move we
only need one velocity for the final
state I have now again let's assume that
there's no external forces there are
clearly internal forces that are acting
between the two particles as they
collide but remember we know that
internal forces cancel in pairs and if
there's no external forces the momentum
of the system is constant so we can
write down our momentum condition very
simply and we'll write it again in terms
of components we have some incoming
momentum into the system and all of that
incoming momentum is going out and now
is energy constant well a totally
inelastic collision energy cannot be
constant and the reason is is that these
internal forces will cause deformations
that are irreversible so the objects
might be deformed which is a loss of and
some of that kinetic energy will go into
deformation there could be noise there
could be heat generated in the collision
lots of sources when objects stick
together kinetic energy is not constant
in fact we can even figure out the
change in kinetic energy because we can
see here that the ex final is m1 over
1 + M 2 V 1 X initial and now let's ask
ourselves in a totally inelastic
collision what is the change in the
kinetic energy so our final kinetic
energy is one-half m1 + m2 v here we can
again write it in terms of components VX
final because the components squared
that's no problem and we just have this
initial kinetic energy coming in now we
have a solution for our problem so let's
just put that in and 1 plus m2 times m1
over m1 plus m2 times v1 X initial
squared minus one-half m1 v1 X initial
squared and now let's pull out the
one-half m1 v1 X initial squared
one-half one factor of m1 v1 x initial
squared but what we're left with here is
another factor of m1 and downstairs we
have an m1 plus m2 outside but m1 plus
m2 now remember we didn't square that we
have an m1 plus m2 inside so there's an
m1 plus m2 minus 1 now this is the
initial kinetic energy and when we
subtract these terms we have negative m2
over m1 plus m2 and so what we see here
is I'm just going to rewrite this again
that the kinetic energy the change in
kinetic energy just depends on the
initial kinetic energy and this mass
ratio in fact if we asked ourselves what
is the ratio of the loss of kinetic
energy to the initial kinetic energy
that just depends on the mass ratio of
our two objects in particular it should
be a minus sign because the kinetic
energies is decreasing and so this is
is the fact it's very transparent now
that in a totally inelastic collision
the kinetic energy is not constant where
did that energy go it went into other
forms of energy